if not entirely surprising I mean we
should be really blunt and frank about
that's trying to shut down in Parliament
in order to force through a new deal
break so that everybody knows will do
real and lasting damage to people the
length and breadth of the UK is not
democracy it's dictatorship and if MPs
do find a way of coming together next
week to stop Boris Johnson in his tracks
then today will go down in history as
the day any semblance of UK democracy
died is this as your breaks it's
actually Michael Russell said a coup
d'etat I think that is a reasonable
description this is an abuse of process
it is whatever Boris Johnson says and
however he tries to dress her up this is
about trying to stop a majority in
parliament coming together to avoid an
ordeal brexit now you know that's the
kind of behavior you expect to see in
countries that are not democratic that
are ruled by dictators and that's
happening here in the UK I mean Boris
Johnson let's not forget is not elected
by anybody other than the Conservative
Party and here he is trying to shut down
Parliament it breaks it was meant to be
supposedly about bringing control back
to the House of Commons and no you have
supposedly got to accept that it it's so
important to force it through in the
worst possible way the Parliament has to
be shut down it is completely outrageous